alors les résultats commencent à arriver
à un salaire on commence à avoir
certaines certaines idées pour le
département de l'orne
qu'est-ce que vous comment vous voyez la
situation d'abord je constate qu'il ya
une participation qui me paraît plus
élevé que sur la moyenne nationale
ce qui veut dire que les ornaises et les
orner se sont déplacés aux urnes et qu'
ils ont souhaité également envoyé un
message à la fois à la majorité mais
également à l'opposition départementale
à travers ses résultats qu'on retrouve
dans tous les cantons
beaucoup de candidats de la droite
auront face à eux un vidéo front
national parce que le front national est
très présent au second tour vous vous y
attendiez les différents sondages qui
sortait ces derniers jours nous indiquer
quand même une front national assez haut
mais c'est vrai que la surprise c'est
d'avoir le parti socialiste par ces
candidats déclarés à 6 mineo caché
qu'ils soient très souvent éliminés dès
le premier tour ce qui démontre bien que
finalement les électrices et des
électeurs ne leur font pas du tout
confiance pour pour gouverner un
département est fait pour gouverner en
proximité et face au front national
vino que la droite a de sérieuses
chances où il faut qu'il y ait un
sursaut après je vais vous dire c'est
programme contre programme personnalités
contre personnalité on a d'un côté
finalement des candidats de la majorité
départementale qui sont prêts à
s'investir pour leur coin pour leur
canton pour leur département qui ont un
vrai programme ambitieux et basé sur la
solidarité sur le désenclavement sur le
numérique sur la modernisation de l'orne
et puis de l'autre des candidats
nationaux qui ont un programme national
qui n'a strictement rien à voir avec des
élections départementales dont je ne
doute pas que les ornaises et les orner
qui ont du bon sens feront le bon choix
donc vous
ne vous n'attendez pas un bouleversement
dans l'eau je sais pas mais nous verrons
ça la semaine prochaine en filigrane est
en train de se dessiner une majorité qui
pourrait être la même que celle qu'il y
avait lors du précédent mandat
mais il faut maintenant que tout cela se
confirme que l'on enfonce le clou et
qu'on fasse encore et toujours une
campagne de proximité pour ce deuxième
tour donc la semaine qui commence va
être importante pour convaincre ceux qui
vont encore voir
ah oui c'est une période là les quelques
jours qui nous séparent de ce deuxième
tour qui va être très très important de
nos candidats vont continuer d'aller sur
le terrain vont présenter leurs projets
vont insister vont aller voir les uns et
les autres et je suis sûr qu ils seront
gagnants le soir de du dimanche 29 vous
c'est fini le terrain vous êtes élu vous
y attendiez je m'y attendais un peu je
veux dire que quelque part c'est une
fierté c'est aussi pour moi un moment
important parce que mon canton a été
agrandi a été redécoupée j'y vois aussi
une marque de reconnaissance de la part
des habitants avec qui je vis au
quotidien pour qui je travaille tous les
jours et je trouve que c'est aussi
rassurant parce que veut dire quand des
élus locaux s'investissent donnent de
leur temps
essaye d'innover son audacieux et bien
les gens suivent d'abord ils ont voté
parce qu'il ya un très bon taux de
participation dans mon canton et ensuite
ils nous font confiance et donc et aussi
même un côté émouvant je trouve